[Musique]
et maintenant le désespoir d'un algérien
de 44 ans sous le coup d'un arrêté
d'expulsion noureddine à midi doit être
renvoyé ce soit vers son pays d'origine
pour un vol commis en france il y avait
24 ans depuis la vie de cet algérien se
résuma long combat pour rester en france
avec sa famille et n'diaye norbert cohen
mais qu'est ce qu'on va faire qu'est ce
que tu vas faire toutes les dix minutes
nordine appelle sa soeur du centre de
rétention du mesnil-amelot en
seine-et-marne
il lui dit lui répète qu'il ne veut pas
partir pourtant le train doit l'emmener
ce soir vers marseille puis ce sera le
bateau pour l'algérie il est sous le
coup d'un arrêté d'expulsion en urgence
absolue de 1971 en 71 nordine avait 20
ans lawrence absolue c'est ce qui est
pire c'est ce qu'il ya de plus haut
c'est donc il comprend pas cette
injustice là donc c'est n'a pas fait de
crimes de guerre de 200 pardon de trafic
de drogue il a fait la délinquance la
petite délinquance c'est vrai qu'il
était à cambrioler
une voiture s'est du coup rien l'âge
abus de confiance aussi été aussi
arrêtés pour abus de confiance mais
jamais pour de gros de gros des vignes
quoi je veux dire depuis 71 nordine à
marie fait des allers retours entre
l'algérie et la france l'algérie où il a
vécu pendant onze ans après son
expulsion met toute sa famille est ici
il a grandi en france et certains de ses
frères et soeurs sont français lui n'a
jamais pu se faire naturaliser à cause
de cette expulsion pour laquelle il ne
peut y avoir prescription revenu en
france en 92 nourdine est en situation
irrégulière
seul le ministère de l'intérieur peut
aujourd'hui abrogé l'arrêté d'expulsion
mais pour celà nordine ne doit plus être
sur le sol français et la procédure peut
durer au moins cinq ans
[Musique]